- Hey good humans.
Before we get into the video,
we wanna thank Google Fi for sponsoring
this portion of the video.
Google Fi is a phone plan by Google.
It's incredibly easy to get
started and you can do it all
from your home.
There's no activation fees
and you don't have to sign a contract.
They offer three plans
and you can either pay
for the data you use
with Google Fi's flexible plan
or choose and unlimited plans
based on your data usage.
I went with a Simply Unlimited Plan,
which is the most affordable plan
for unlimited data, calls and texts.
So dad, you don't have to tell me
I'm using up all of our data
anymore because it's unlimited.
It also has great privacy
and security features.
When you enable Google Fi's VPN,
your online connect is private
and you have more protection from hackers.
So even if I'm connected
to wifi at a coffee shop
or an airport,
my cellular and wifi
traffic will be encrypted.
You can bring your own
phone to any Google Fi plan
which makes Fi accessible, no
matter what phone you have.
Thanks again to Google Fi
for sponsoring this part of the video.
Now let's get into it
- And we're gonna go boom, like this
and you can see, I'm not
slapping, I'm not chopping.
You wanna be gliding.
- This is hot.
(upbeat music)
Hey, I'm Alyssa
- And I'm Motoki and this
is "Expert Amateur Fraud"
a show where we try to
figure out who the expert is
and who's faking in.
- And today we're gonna
be interviewing three,
drum roll please,
(hands drumming)
chefs!
- Whoa. Okay.
- Okay.
- We're about to eat good.
- Oh my gosh. Okay.
- Fancy-schmancy.
- Now it's real.
- It's hard to tell
whether or not someone's a pro or a fake,
but I've also seen the
movie "Ratatouille".
So I don't know, I feel like
I'm pretty knowledgeable
about this, to be honest with you.
- And that was like, I feel
weird that I haven't seen that.
- Oh, interesting.
- Yeah.
(air swooshing)
(upbeat jazz music)
- [Motoki] Come on in.
- [Alyssa] Hey, welcome. (hands clapping)
- [Motoki] Howdy. Howdy.
- Hi.
- Thank you so much
for coming to my house.
(all laughing)
- Oh, I love your house.
Beautiful.
- It's a pretty spacious, open concept.
- Hi, I'm Shauen.
- Hi Shauen.
- Howdy.
- And I have for you
a Thai shepherd's pie.
- Oo, a shepherd's pie?
I love a little shepherds pie.
- A Thai shepherds pie? It rhymes.
So what are the ingredients of this one?
- So the base is ground beef.
There's eggplant, peas, carrots.
- [Alyssa] Mm.
- The Thai comes in from
the Thai chili paste.
It might be a little spicy.
(flames roaring)
- Okay.
- That's all right.
I'm down.
- Looking at me.
Looking at me. (laughing)
- I made it because I
kinda wanted to tie it
to what I want to teach you guys
- A Thai it, to it?
(Shauen and Alyssa laughing)
- That was a very generous laugh.
(Shauen laughing)
- I wanted to tie this into
what I wanted to teach you
which is how to build flavor.
My philosophy is that
cooking is a language.
So the more you know about it,
the more you can say
what you want with food.
- Cooking is like its own language.
There's all like T B S P.
What does that mean?
(all laughing)
- [Motoki] Is there an eating technique?
- Oh yeah, for sure.
How it is on your spoon kind of matters.
- Oh really?
- Yeah. You don't want
too much of the beef.
You don't want too much
of the mash potatoes.
you kind of want a whole experience.
- I love that.
- You've seen Ratatouille, right?
- (scoffing) Of course.
- Yeah.
- I feel weird I haven't seen that.
- So you know how he eats
that strawberry and cheese
and there's those notes.
- Yes. Feel it. (fireworks exploding)
- I want you to really think
about the flavors in there.
- [Motoki] I wanna be
encompassed by the flavor.
- I appreciate that.
- You wanna see the sweetness.
You wanna feel a little tartness
from the tomato-based curry.
- Mmm.
- I feel the spice a little bit.
- There's a little butter
in there for lusciousness.
- [Alyssa] Oh my God.
This is amazing.
- That's that fatty flavor.
- This is the real deal.
- That's a great combo. Yeah.
I feel like they all compliment
each other really well.
(air swooshing)
- I always emphasize trying new things.
There's so much food out there.
Why would you wanna
eat only grilled cheese
for the rest of your life?
When you could have a
thousand different kinds
of grilled cheese with
all the cheeses out there.
(light music)
- Hey.
- [Motoki] Welcome in.
- Welcome.
- Thank you.
- Join the party. Please.
How's it going?
- What's your name?
- My name is Gil.
- Nice to meet you.
That is a big knife.
- Look, he brought his own
knife. Oh, when he got an onion.
- Can you guess what we're gonna do?
- Chop onions.
- Yes.
- Are we?
- Specifically, we are
learning knife skills.
- Oh.
- Oh my God.
- Because if you don't have that,
you're not going to be
able to cook anything.
- Are we gonna cry?
- Only if you fail.
- I definitely will cry.
I cry like profusely.
- So the first step is
you gotta know how to pick up your knife
and you are already failing,
holding it by blade.
Come on.
(Motoki laughing)
So why don't you guys
put the down your knives.
We're gonna pick 'em up together.
- Put down your swords.
- [Motoki] This is process.
- [Gil] Okay, so you're
gonna grab it by the handle.
Go for it.
- [Alyssa] That's classic.
- Now walk your fingers forward.
- Oh.
- Your thumb should be actually
on the side of the blade
and your other finger
wrapped around this way.
- This is like pool, billiards.
- Sure. Yeah.
First step is you take this side.
Cut. That's all you need to get off.
This side, all you need to get rid of
is this little part, right there.
Root side up. Go halfway down.
Boom. Like that.
- Whoa.
- So the next, now watch this look
the skin just comes right off.
- That's cool.
- Oh my gosh.
- Super easy. Super easy.
- Real. It's a real onion.
- That's actually great.
- That's really cool.
- I'm genuinely thinking about
all the time that I am wasting.
- Yeah. I've never seen an
onion, bare naked, like that.
I've never seen it. (all laughing)
- No, I've never seen its naked body.
- What? Do you do cook with the skin on?
- Yeah.
- You're not supposed to?
- Oh boy. We might need
a little more time.
- Yeah.
- [Gil] Find the flat side.
Take the knife.
The onion is round.
So you don't wanna just go down
and we're gonna go boom, like this,
and you see, I'm not
slapping, I'm not chopping.
You wanna be gliding.
- This is hot.
Now. Are there onions in the
thing you cooked for us today?
- Yes.
- Oh, there are? Oo.
- Oh my gosh, Gil. What?
- [Motoki] Okay. What do you call this?
- So these are
Vietnamese-style fresh rolls.
So inside we got some fresh
herbs, lettuce, cilantro, mint,
crispy pork belly, grilled onions.
And then this is a peanut
butter chili garlic sauce.
- It's kind of, this is
intimidating in a sense
'cause I feel like in a
restaurant you would never
eat this right in front of the chef.
- Okay. Here goes, I'm gonna
go for it.
- Bon appetite.
Oh yeah, get it.
A little cilantro out the mouth, baby.
- Yeah. Don't sleep on that sauce.
You gotta keep pouring it in there.
- Just keep it going?
Even though I have a peanut allergy?
No, I'm joking.
- Gil, this is amazing.
Gil has a really like confident presence
which is needed in the kitchen.
To me, this is five stars.
(Motoki and Alyssa laughing)
- I'd say the first
thing that will tell you
that somebody doesn't know what
they're doing in the kitchen
is looking at their knife skills.
Which is why I decided
to use that as my skill.
Because when you get
into professional cooking
knife skills is the first
thing that you learn.
(air swooshing)
(upbeat jazz music)
- Hello.
- Come on in.
Whoa look at this.
- Hi, oh my goodness.
- This is a salmon dish.
- Oo.
- And bok choy with mushrooms.
- This looks amazing.
- I hope you guys are hungry.
- Oh my gosh.
Wait, what's your name?
- My name is Lillian.
- Lillian. Thank you so much for coming.
- Thank you for having me.
- What made you choose these dishes?
- These are my favorites.
It's also something simple to make.
'cause I feel like
sometimes people are like,
"Oh, cooking is too hard."
But it's actually it comes down-
- This is simple? It looks complicated.
- Trust me. Simple ingredients.
- [Motoki] This looks delicious.
- Here I have ginger,
garlic, mushrooms, bok choy
all that has to be processed.
Oh and onions that you
probably already had enough of.
- We know onions.
(musical flourish)
Let tell you.
- Yes. You said this is something
that your family has done before
and then you're kind
of taking it on. Okay.
- Is that what a lot of your dishes are?
Do you think?
- I think so.
- You're like, I'm not picky.
So this is gonna be
impossible for me to decipher.
Who's who.
- I can't believe it. I
need to like give you $20.
(cash register ringing)
- Oh wow.
- It's so good.
- Five stars.
- I'd love that.
- Even like restaurants, aren't this good?
Like I feel like I'm eating
like a home cooked gourmet meal.
Like it feels like I'm in your house
with you and your family.
(laughing)
- What if I just opened the curtain up
and they just walk in.
- Hello!
- Actually they cooked it. No. (laughing)
- Maybe?
- Maybe, you never know.
- I'm shook.
And I can't believe that
you're just here with me,
feeding me this delicious food.
- It's also super healthy, which is great.
- That's also some I like.
I think food should be,
it should feel good.
It should taste good. Yeah.
- Feel good. Taste good.
- Buy now.
- That also sounds like
something a chef would say
- No, really great job.
- Thank you.
- Super delicious.
- This is gonna be so hard.
Deciding who the heck is the real chef.
'Cause like so far I'm like everybody.
(all laughing)
- Food is my love language.
I love to cook for
friends, family members,
anyone who I'm able to
invite into my home.
The way that people interact
with me when they taste my food
and they're just so
happy and they're like,
"Wow you cooked this for me."
I'm like, "Why not?
"Yeah. I cooked this for you."
And I just love that feeling.
- I literally have never
been this confused.
- I don't know.
- The last time I was this confused
was when I was trying
to learn multiplication.
- Do you have any instincts?
Like right now, from the Get Go?
- I do have like sort of instincts.
- Tell me.
- Lillian was the
sweetest, but in my mind,
I think think she just talked too much
about kind of like family dishes.
Which made me think that
maybe she is the fraud.
Her dish was incredible,
but do you know what I mean?
- Yeah, I have situations
like that too, where I'm like,
"Oh I've made this,
because my mom made this."
- Yes. Absolutely.
- So it's like, you know.
- Also that's the thing,
Lillian could literally own
a family owned restaurant and be the chef.
That's literally a thing.
- That's true.
- My initial thought was
that Shauen was the expert.
The way that he talked about
all of the flavor profile stuff.
- You just have to judge the material.
- What did you think
of Gil? The onion guy.
- Gil was good,
but maybe we have to peel
back the layers of the onion
and we find out that he's in amateur.
- Wow. That's-
- What do you think about that?
- I just got goosebumps.
I got goosebumps when he said that.
(upbeat music)
- Hello again?
- Hello. Welcome.
Welcome back. Hey Guys.
- It's been so long.
We're outnumbered. So if we're wrong...
- We're gonna get, cut.
- We think the expert is Shauen, right?
- The flavor conversation and the layers
and there was just something different
about the way they kind
of addressed their dish.
And I'm so sorry. If it's not true.
(dramatic music)
(buzzer buzzing)
- Oh my gosh.
- You got us. That was good.
- What? Oh my gosh.
I'm actually like, okay
now I have a feeling
that we were wrong in every single one.
- We thought the amateur was
Gil.
- Gil.
the onion connoisseur.
- Yes. Which now possibly he's an expert.
But we thought prior it was amateur.
(tense music)
(buzzer buzzing)
- Oh my gosh.
- Nice, nice.
(hands slapping)
- Oh, we were wrong.
- Zero for two.
- You know what? We wanted
to be wrong, actually.
Okay.
- Last but not least.
- Hello Lilian.
- Hello.
- We think you're the fraud
but we're zero for two.
So we'll see.
- Right. We could be completely wrong.
The reason why we said that
was because we were like,
oh it felt just kind of
like, the food was amazing,
but we were like, oh this is
just kind of her family dishes.
And we both said,
"Oh yeah we can make like
our family classics."
- I don't know. I feel
like we could get this one.
- You think?
- Yeah.
(tense music)
(bell ringing)
- Oh my gosh.
- I told you.
Yes, let's go.
- Wow. Okay, so Gil, expert.
- Yes, you're the expert, I'm assuming.
- Yes.
- Okay.
- I knew it. I felt it.
- I've been in food
service for over 10 years.
I've been out of culinary
school about six years or so.
And I've been working for about five years
as a private chef.
When I was in culinary school
there were a lot of people that signed up
thinking it was just gonna
be a fun cooking class.
And those people all dropped out.
When you realize that
you're gonna be there
hours and hours a day.
As long as you're willing to
do all that you can do it,
but it's not for everybody.
- Shauen, amateur?
- Yep.
- What is, does that look like?
- I am in school for food science.
- Oh!
- Okay.
You made it so casually.
You're like, yeah, I
just cook a lot at home.
- [Alyssa] Yeah.
- So I actually started school
with an idea to get into nursing.
A semester in, I found
out about food science
and these are the people
that work on like your
favorite flavor of cereal.
You know, the research
that it goes into that.
- You guys are all amazing though.
- Yeah. It was great.
Thanks for sharing your dish too, Lilian.
It was good.
- Yeah. Thank you.
- And it's part of your family.
So we got to experience
that. That's great.
- My grandma loves to cook.
I think she should start a restaurant.
My mom took after her.
So I definitely learned from them
and being at home during the pandemic.
- The now did you actually cook
the food that you brought today?
- I did.
- Oh wow. You're not a fraud.
- My dishes. It was me.
It was all me.
The distinction between fraud and amateur
for the purpose of the show,
being the professional experience
or like the educational experience.
'cause I'm not going
to school for cooking.
I never took lessons
for any of these culinary tips
that I know or tricks.
Versus for me, it's like a hobby.
In eighth grade I developed
an eating disorder.
I had anorexia nervosa and
just, it was really, really bad.
I didn't really appreciate
my mom's cooking.
But she put so much
love and time and energy
to make sure that I was healthy.
And okay, so to me food is,
it's so much more than just a meal.
You know, I just am really grateful
that my relation to food has improved.
Whatever motive you have,
whatever relationship you have to food.
I just really pray that
it is a healthy one.
And it's one that fulfills
you and makes you feel joy.
That's all. Just to feel joy around food.
(upbeat music)